All the basic features of romance,
Bourbon, the helping verbs.
You'll meet this time also.
Yeah,
that reflect those same basic features,
so you'll need to be familiar with them.
Can Be present,
indicative IBS,
predatory rbst or present subjunctive
IBS to throw just a few forms your way
with all of those endings in mind.
Take a look at to helping verbs.
I bet. Eh, an s setting. Why can
they act as helping verbs? Well,
they sometimes sit next to a
meaning heavy verb like Cantara,
but do most of the grammatical
work.
The main content for in this example is
in some invariable born less variable
forms.
These forms are typically nonpersonal.
They carry no person number
information in their ending.
You've met one of these forms already.
The infinitive light got Darren,
but verbs also have a past participle.
Like
these can be adjectives as
in vegetable can tattoo,
but they're also very handy and
phrases with our Beta [inaudible],
Jarons and present participles also exist.
Rewind to that example I
showed you with can tattoo.
Perfect.
What's going on here?
It's the same thing that
happens in English. Have some,
the main grammatical verb have isn't
the same as the main content from sun
in French, Italian and other
central romance languages.
The verb aesthetic comes into play with
verbs of motion at other verbs that
don't take direct objects. As
said, it has unexpected forms.
So for venue to come we find
is 22 and these languages
[inaudible] La Vinny
with [inaudible] participles describe
the person performing the action so they
have to match the number
and gender of the subject.
He Lou Phil You is 22 verses Isla Philia
is Venita not so with our Betty Elu
Phileo at he left Phelia at Kentucky
Iberian and Romanian languages
use Ebay with all verbs.
Venita included Avenida I've a neat
Romanian Italian romance.
French and Sardinian use this perfect
tense for their regular past tense instead
of the Predator.
It can tie,
which we find for example in
formal written Italian or French,
compare this to Spanish or Portuguese
which continue the use of Kuntai
colloquially.
It is some,
it is done.
This same way of forming the passive is
founded in romance with aesthetic plus a
past participle Cantata scree.
But I meant to write script too.
It's the past participle written.
What do you think as scraped domains?
That's a perfect construction.
What about s scrape too?
That's a passive.
There's another very popular
romance passive that goes like this,
says Cribbet.
Literally it writes itself,
which we'll learn about later.
The help of romance,
helping verbs doesn't stop there.
Modal verbs like the auxiliaries
can want to need to or ought to,
our mood verbs that introduce
an infinitive [inaudible].
Another use of auxiliaries.
Western romance languages
have the equivalent of Goto
before an infinitive for
near future events.
Much like English does
vacant you've vegetable tea and
one more use of helping verbs.
Western romance languages,
not including French.
Can you start it as a helping verb
with a Jaron to point out something
done right now.
Start Cantando
stumbles
Sardinian users s set in this same way.
Socket
sames contaminate
and I bet it get a lot of it
mileage and the modern languages
beyond their users. Auxiliaries.
I bet it is hurting many
everyday phrases like
as family and [inaudible]
a series the Copula we're linking verb
luck Cassez Manga or Eley Fiji tsunamis.
Okay.
If you've been following along so far,
I congratulate you.
You've made it through romance
verbs and now you're prepared.
Rona.